Madonna analyses ruling that repletion
ayats of an electron ocean via the
mukesh github response on board made an
order octave lower carter and to make
damn it beginning via in the australian
destroy and vida meet in morocco
minister and took the line and domino it
has fought petition please could you
give minister took the line and there
yes no honorable members pollutant
errors they are fundamental for the
conservation of biodiversity and for
life on earth they are essential for
food production and human livelihoods
they are key to supporting our
ecosystems pollinators are also
important for the economy their impact
is particularly visible in food
production almost 15 billion euros of
the EU's annual agricultural output is
directly attributed to insect
pollinators for many crops the
contribution of pollinators can amount
to half of the market value of producing
over the past decade the number and
diversity of pollinators have seriously
declined in Europe as well as globally
many of them are threatened with
extinction this situation is
unsustainable the functioning of our
ecosystem and human wellbeing are at
risk many different drivers contribute
to the decline of pollinators and they
are all linked to human activity much
pollinator habitat has been lost to
agriculture resource extraction and new
urban and sub urban development
non-native species take away the natural
habitat of the pollinators and
unfamiliar parasites and diseases
conceivably severely compromised whole
colonies of bees intensive farming and
the use of harmful pesticides are
another big threat for pollinators
destroying their habitat and taking away
the diversity of the plants they usually
forage on climate change and temperature
changes also have disruptive effects on
pollination ladies and gentlemen I agree
with you that we need effective measures
in the EU to address the root causes of
pollinators decline the Commission made
an important first step in this
direction by adopting in June last year
and EU initiative especially focusing on
pollinators the council welcomes this
initiative which seeks to address the
problem in an indirect related way and
to use existing tools and policies more
effectively like the European Parliament
the council is of the view that in order
to tackle the loss of pollinators more
research is needed to address knowledge
gaps and to clearly understand the
causes and the consequences of the
decline pollinator species and
populations in the EU also need to be
better monitored to better understand
their status and trends only with
scientific knowledge and a full
understanding of the problem can we
address it effectively it is also
important to raise public awareness
about pollinators and they're important
for healthy ecosystems and for our
well-being the European Parliament is
right in stressing the need to engage
citizens beekeepers and farmers to
contribute to pollinator conservation
and the industry citizens and
governments at all levels have to join
efforts international cooperation is
another important aspect the conference
of the parties to the UN Convention on
Biological Diversity agreed on a plan of
action for 2018 to 2030 for the
conservation and sustainable use of
pollinators in the action plan State
holder's including farmers are
encouraged to adapt pollinator friendly
practices and address direct and
indirect drivers of pollinator decline
and our member states are active in
raising the problem of pollinators
decline in the international community
11 member states have joined the
Coalition of the Willing on pollinators
established in 2016 at the 13th meeting
of the Conference of the parties to the
convention of biological diversity in
cancun the members of the coalition
committed to take action and to work
together on pollinators and to share the
knowledge and the best practices to
encourage other countries to take
measures in this respect last month
the Coalition proposed to have a
specific target an indicator for in for
pollinators and pollination in the
post-2020 global biodiversity framework
perhaps the most important and burden of
the priority actions identified by the
Commission in the EU pollinators
initiative is to tackle the causes of
pollinator decline the EU has already
put in place a range of measures such as
the protection of natural habitats
through the EU nature legislation
support for beekeeping and restrictions
on the use of pesticides harmful to bees
the EU Natura 2000 network of protected
areas provides many habitats of vital
importance for pollinators yet
these measures have not been sufficient
measures have also been taken to promote
pollinator friendly solutions in
agriculture and to support biodiversity
in the reformed common agricultural
policy for the years 2014 to 2020 all
these developments are positive but
despite the action taken so far the
decline of pollinators has not stopped
the intergovernmental science policy
platform on par on biodiversity and
ecosystem services report global
assessment on biodiversity and ecosystem
services released in May this year
provides a green Pig
and the global decline of biodiversity
at unpresentable history is to a large
extent caused by the loss of pollinators
which are the very basis of habitats and
ecosystems vulnerable members to
conclude it is clear we have not done
enough and more efforts are needed to
halt the decline of pollinators and
maintain and restore their habitats the
council therefore called for rapid and
effective implementation of the existing
measures by the EU and the member states
to address the loss of biodiversity the
council also welcomes the European Green
Deal adopted by the Commission last week
we also look forward to the publication
of the Commission's by diversity
strategy for 2030 with ambitious targets
on biodiversity for biodiversity which
we will examine with great interest as
soon as it's available thank you very
much madam president for your attention
thank you and once more sorry for the
desk so we follow by will be followed by
the Commission Commissioner kiriakidis
you have the floor please Thank You
president honourable members I am
addressing this point on behalf of my
colleague commissioners in Quebec use
the decline of what pollinators in the
European Union is as you have said
dramatic the functioning of ecosystems
our food security and well-being are at
risk this problem has vividly captured
as we all know public attention in 2016
the European Parliament called on the
Commission and Member States tracked
urgently on this problem in 2018 the
Commission adopted the first-ever
European Union initiative on pollinators
building on European research projects
and following a broad public
consultation this initiative sets long
term objectives and short term actions
providing the necessary framework to
consolidated efforts across sectors and
to provide a more effective response of
the European Union and
it's member-states the scope is
comprehensive more than 30 actions aim
to strengthen understanding of the
problem tackle the main drivers and
engage actors across the board main
threats to pollinators are well known
the initiative addresses directly the
loss of pollinator habitats and the use
of pesticides particularly in the
context of agriculture it also addresses
directly the threat from invasive alien
species the already existing and future
European Union actions on research
climate change and pollution will also
be critical for the protection of
pollinators agriculture is the key
sector it does depend on pollinators but
also exerts a strong pressure on them
whether through intensification of
agricultural practices or abandonment of
high nature value farmland our common
agricultural policy is essential to turn
these challenges into opportunities the
role of Member States is critical the
future Common Agricultural Policy in
particular offers them a significant
opportunity to improve and scale up
their actions on pollinators as
announced in the European Green Deal and
while we are still waiting for the
adoption of the new C ap the Commission
will work with Member States to ensure
that strategic plans are assessed
according to robust and environmental
criteria and lead to more sustainable
practices these include precision
agriculture organic farming Agricola G
and ensure these plans work towards the
goal of stopping the loss of pollinators
the Commission is currently developing a
common European Union monitoring scheme
for pollinator species in close
cooperation with Member States the
scheme will mobilize scientists citizens
and practitioners to generate data
necessary to build robust policy
indicators on the status and the trends
of the pollinated species this
we'll ensure that we have the necessary
knowledge to assess the effects of our
policies including the Common
Agricultural Policy on the diversity and
on the abundance of pollinators the
responsible the responsibility to deploy
to dually deploy the monitoring scheme
on the ground lies with Member States
the Commission will coordinate and
provide the necessary support including
through the Future Life program and of
course horizon Europe the European Union
pollinators initiative is also
developing monitoring processes for
pressures on pollinators including
pesticides this will support research on
the causes of pollinator declines and
better understanding how to effectively
tackle them the initiative aims to
reduce the impacts of pesticides on
pollinators by strengthening the risk
assessment banning all outdoor uses of
the three neonicotinoids restricted in
2013 supporting member states to ensure
the sustainable use of pesticides in
particularly through integrated pest
management in the European Green Deal
the Commission announced an increased
level of ambition to tackle the cause of
biodiversity loss including by reducing
significantly barriers and the risk of
chemical pesticides as well as the use
of fertilisers and restoring damaged
ecosystems the Commission will identify
the measures including legislative
needed to bring about these reductions
and finally the biodiversity strategy
for 2013 and the farm to fork strategy
to be delivered in the spring of 2020
will provide strong frameworks for the
European Union pollinators initiative
and help us reach our goal of stopping
the loss of pollinators yet sinned and
become a sovereign on yet stoked in the
outer part of our colleague and
McGuinness video appears of work spot a
enemy neutralized his petition tankers
air and thank you both